[Music]  yeah  a senator lady got the news one day the  country is being spied on by the NSA  so she went out defendant on each TV  says when she found out she'd been  snooped on she got all upset and isn't  it ironic I mean don't you think  like you're a Chris Brown and a punchy  enough  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  senator this may surprise you and the  irony invites the comes people ain't the  only ones with Fourth Amendment rights  it's like a minimalist does their  laundry with all Woody Allen like to  watch kids in the hall  it's like FDR  she just can't  really hated that  in Figure  I heard the government shaking up on you  life has a funny funny way  calling  I study the Constitution myself I am  reasonably well educated and I thank you  for the lecture